welcome to Carnegie Mellon online for
more multimedia from Carnegie Mellon
University
visit
okay so what I'm going to be talking
about here is represents a pretty
long-term large research project but I'm
not going to present it that way
I'm not going to sort of present it the
way I would to fellow researchers it's
right after lunch and I'm not the only
person person I'm sure who gets sleepy
after lunch so instead I'm going to
present it to you to you in a way that
is sort of I hope designed to answer the
kinds of questions you might have come
with so let me just ask before I start
how many of you grew up in Pittsburgh
what all right good good so I bet you
have heard of Pittsburgh ease before or
at least I bet that you've heard of it
recently I don't think this term was
around much before the 60s for about the
1960s but I'll talk about that I'll talk
about that little bit more later so
here's a here's what I'm going to try to
get through first of all what are some
of the features of Pittsburgh ease and
where do they come from
what's the history of this dialect I'm
going to try to talk about some of the
other sources of influences we'll see
there's sort of one main historical
source of influence that has given rise
to this dialect but there are some other
sources as well and then is pittsburgh
is going to die out or is it going to
persist and finally if there's time I
want to talk about the role of what I
call the Pittsburgh diaspora and I
suppose I wouldn't wouldn't be surprised
if some of you were people who grew up
in Pittsburgh but don't live here now in
shaping ideas about local speech it
turns out that Pittsburghers who don't
live in Pittsburgh anymore are a major
source of kind of discourse about
attention to pride in local speech
that's one place where it really comes
up and it's always been connected with
movement so a little bit of Pennsylvania
history for those of you who like me
have forgotten what they learned in
eighth grade early settlers in
Pennsylvania brought their languages and
dialects with them the Quakers were
among the first to come as
you know probably Philadelphia was
founded by Quakers for Quakers and they
didn't just settle in that area they
moved westward there's still quite a few
old Quaker families in central
Pennsylvania where I grew up but not as
many in this part of the state
most of the Quakers found good farming
land on the other side of the Allegheny
Mountains so that the Quakers around
here tend to be more allied with Quakers
and in the Midwest further west than
with the ones in the east also Germans
lots of Germans in this area the Germans
kind of hopscotched with a scots-irish
who are the next group but the Germans
got a lot of the see what people were
looking for was good land they had
brought their seeds and stuff with them
and they want a good land and of the
Germans took took got most of the really
rich agricultural land in central and
eastern Pennsylvania so in Centre County
where I grew up most of the old names
are German names most the old farmers
the old farming families have either
Quaker or German ancestry the
scots-irish were came from Scotland
that's where they embarked but many
that's what their families originally
embarked from but many came from
families that had lived for several
generations in Northern Ireland so there
was a time in the 1600s when the the
English royalty decided to settle
colonize Northern Ireland to sort of
subdue the the locals by moving a lot of
people over from Scotland and the Ulster
area of Northern Ireland what's now
Northern Ireland as opposed to the
Republic of Ireland is very heavily
settled by these people there's a
different very quite different dialect
in that part of Ireland that sounds a
lot more like lowland Scottish English
or Scots but then around starting at
around 1717 30s but really accelerating
during the 1700s and in this area mostly
around the late 1700s right around the
time of the American Revolution and
after
afterwards many scots-irish came and
settled in this area they tended to have
smaller more hardscrabble farms because
a lot of the good farming land wasn't
available anymore they tended to live in
the mountains they tended to be farmers
and grow a lot of grain because they
could grow grain but it took a long time
to get the grain back over the Allegheny
Mountains to market and you couldn't it
would have rotted by the time we tore
whatever would have rotted by the time
it got to Philadelphia to the port so
what could they do except turn it into
whiskey and this really was an economic
decision this really was this really was
about getting your crop to market but
they also drank some of it and they've
gotten a reputation now as you know
these hard drive hard drinking
moonshiners which really isn't isn't
quite accurate it was an economic thing
but they were largely responsible for
the whiskey rebellion after the American
Revolution when the government tried to
the US government the new US government
tried to raise some money to pay back
their war expenses by tacked taxing
whiskey and since the local people in
this area we're extremely dependent on
whiskey they rebelled against that and
that started right outside of Pittsburgh
now as you can see there were there are
lots of lots of evidence that these
early scots-irish here on the right is a
gravestone at which is in the cross
creek Presbyterian Church Cemetery Cross
Creek is over west of here near the West
Virginia border and it has a very old
graveyard associated with a Presbyterian
Church these scots-irish were
Presbyterians the southern Irish were of
course Catholic so that was another
reason for this kind of cultural
difference her name was Mary McKibben a
typical scots-irish name the part of
this life June 26 in the seventy third
year of her life so that means she would
have emigrated to this area around the
time when a lot of the scots-irish did
so she was probably this is probably
represents the first generation of
English speakers born in the
area did some in some way you can see
there's still lots of names from
Northern Ireland around here our moth
I went over route 22 and took a few
pictures of road signs in Armagh
Pennsylvania because I had a colleague
and who was from Northern Ireland who
didn't believe me when I said there was
an arm up n Sylvania but there's plenty
of other names like Strabane is a
scots-irish name you could just go
through a map of Pennsylvania and you'd
find a lot of names from England and the
east and a lot of names from Northern
Ireland and in the western part a lot of
these many of the scots-irish actually
weren't from Scotland some of them were
Huguenots I mean so it was a mixture
some of them were more ethnic Irish but
largely they're thought of as
scots-irish then later of course during
the 19th century there were huge numbers
of other groups but not a whole not so
many of anyone that they kind of took
over Irish in the sense of the southern
Irish the potato famine Irish you came
around a middle of the 19th century
african-americans who started coming to
Pittsburgh from the south actually
earlier than to other northern cities
and had a very distinctive culture and
still do have a distinctive culture and
a distinctive way of speaking although
it's not the same as the distinctive
white way of speaking it shares some
features immigrants from continental
Europe now this is these are the
immigrants that most people think of
first when they think of immigrants to
Pittsburgh these are the people from
Croatia Poland
you know the Serbians the Italians the
poles rusyns probably have left out half
the groups that maybe some of you come
from these people came to work in the
steel mills and mostly between about
1880 and 1920 then they're currently
immigrants to Pittsburgh to more and
more Central and Central Americans
particularly Mexicans who are settling
in communities like Beachview in the
South Hills where they can take the tea
to the trolley to get to get to work a
lot of East Asians
Indians and so on who are associated
with the universities and with
professional practices and many live in
Monroeville I'm sure you've seen the
temple out there of your premise area in
South Asians Russians a lot of Russian
Jewish immigrants in Squirrel Hill so
you hear Russians on the street
now a lot in Squirrel Hill so there are
still and there so there's still
migration people complain about how few
people are moving to this area but there
are some so the dialect situation now
most scholars agree that there are now
three major dialect areas in the US and
I'll show you a map in a minute
Pittsburgh is in the North Midland or
lower north area depending how you
divide things up pittsburgh speech and
this will surprise you has one
pronunciation feature that's more or
less idiosyncratic that is there's one
thing that people around pittsburgh do
that nobody else does from all the
research that's been done everything
else are that people think of as
pittsburgh are shared with many speakers
elsewhere so is there a pittsburgh
dialect well in some sense yes because
there's a kind of constellation a set of
things that you hear here that you don't
hear anywhere else but in another sense
no because there's really only one thing
that people do here they don't do
anywhere else and that is the
pronunciation of owl is a downtown or at
and you know pass this is one of the
ones that gets made fun of a lot that
gets sort of as a kind of standard
conventionalized spelling but I'll go
through some of the other ones in in a
moment and I think you'll recognize them
when you hear them but maybe be
surprised to hear that they're not just
heard at Pittsburgh so here's a here's a
map that's there's no point or over
there I didn't think of that
um anyway I can reach it there's a this
is what's sort of thought of as the
south and many one characteristic
feature here is that people pronounce
words like my my asthma then there's the
the North which is becoming even more
and more different from the midland says
where people say Chicago if you compare
the speech of someone
is going to do this million times here
in Cleveland with someone from
Pittsburgh now two and a half hours away
their speech is markedly different very
different you can immediately tell the
difference between a young person from
Cleveland and one from Pittsburgh and it
not even when they're speaking in a
non-standard sort of way not even when
they're you know not trying to speak
correctly but when they're really being
careful about it we have a linguistic
student who just left from the
University of Pittsburgh whose name was
Natalie who was from Cleveland and one
of the little kids who that little kid
of my colleague at Pitt who's also a
linguist his little four-year-old son
noticed that she didn't speak the same
thing the same as he did and he went
around for about a very long day saying
the Italy has any accent and of course
Natalie told him that he had an accent
too but I mean nobody ever believes that
so and then there's some kind of City
areas that are surrounded and then alone
among almost any city there's a little
circle around st. Louis here's the
Pittsburgh area so there are if you're
just looking at pronunciation the way
the the project was that created this
map you would find an area of a western
Pennsylvania area I think it's a mistake
to have Erie in that I think that's just
a I think that's just they didn't have
room they didn't interview very many
people and I think was they must have
interviewed someone from Pittsburgh who
was living in Erie
because people in Erie don't have the
same accent don't you you well whether
you know or not they don't okay so I'm
just going to talk about some of the
pronunciation features we'd call these
phonological features this is really the
first one is really hard to hear and
don't feel bad if you don't hear it
there's two vowel sounds that some
people pronounce differently and hear
differently but most people don't
pronounce differently this is across the
country so I'm one of the minority who
does hear and pronounce these vowels
differently for me the word n ot is not
the same as the word na u ght one is not
and one is not one Co T is caught and ca
you
tht is caught and although I don't
actually say them very differently I've
definitely hear them as belonging
different categories how many of you
hear those is belonging in different
categories yeah so quite a few I think
it's more tends to be more older people
than younger people but I'm I'm from
central Pennsylvania and all my friends
thought they were the same and I thought
they were different I don't really know
why except maybe my parents who were not
from there teaching me to read I mean
this is one of those things that you can
actually learn from learning to read if
you're if the person who is teaching you
to read says keep saying no that's not
not it's not that might sort of force
you to think well maybe there's a
difference here but what's so what's
happening here is that these are
becoming merged merged means they're -
sounds are turning into one that's very
common in the history of languages it's
happened repeatedly in the history of
English and it's happening throughout
the u.s. the difference is that around
here people pronounce this the resulting
one sound not as not but is not so
people from this area this is one of the
things that's very very audible to me
that I can hear immediately when people
say not or caught instead of not or
caught there was the only people that
notice have ever noticed this though are
Outsiders Pittsburghers don't notice it
so there was a cartoon of Rob Rogers
cartoon and Rob Rogers is a very good
cartoonist in the Post Gazette and one
time he had a cartoon about what a fancy
upscale mall would look like if it were
in Pittsburgh the typical kind of you
know what does everything look like if
it's about two degrees more
working-class and there was a body shop
bo dy shop except it was spelled ba wdy
but the joke was funnier if for you
those are actually two different words
so then there's a the one I talked about
before them an organization of Al one
organization means a diphthong which is
two sounds ow or ie or L or ie those are
diphthong
maybe not in writing necessarily but in
speaking and they turn into a
monophthong that is one sound so L
becomes an eye becomes that's it that
second one is a typical southern thing
it really tends to only happen before
elves and ours in this area so it's not
the whole scale southern my nobody you
don't really hear that too often but you
do hear towel for tile and you also hear
towel for towel so that's one of a
there's a few words there's a number of
pairs of words that can sound the same -
and they do sound the same and the only
way to tell the difference is by
figuring out the context but and usually
that's easy to do so it doesn't this
doesn't really cause a lot of problems
but a lot of outsiders have stories
about running into communicative
difficulties as a result of this like am
I actually to have one-to-one walking my
dog very early on when I got here in the
park in the morning you know I don't
know how how many of you do this but you
just tend to talk to other dog people
about what you're going to do during the
day just about nothing and this one guy
from Squirrel Hill said that what he was
going to do is have workmen come and
replace the towels in his bathroom and I
thought that way why can you do that
yourself
um so that you know it was a not a big
problem
momentary little moment like that aisle
and owl for example can sound the same
and that often goes with this final
thing which is that the final L can
sound like a W sometimes so I didn't say
towel
I said towel towel the L turns into more
of a w it's vocalize more like a vowel
that's very very common around here even
people who are really aware of their
accent really trying not to speak that
way will vocalize Elle's I do it myself
then Ian you can both turn into a sort
of a more relaxed sound so instead of E
it's sometimes if instead of ooh is
sometimes oh so a lot of people around
here would pronounced feel and fill the
same way I feel bad you know he's out on
the fill and then fool and full a like
pool and pull a lot of people don't
pronounce pool and pull differently this
is not particularly Pittsburgh I mean
people think of it as Pittsburgh
sometimes it's made fun of in the little
jokes but it's not really a Pittsburgh
thing so much as it's everywhere then
there's this eagle which is very strange
in giant eagle but nobody
yeah but nobody actually says that I
mean that's not really help its workers
pronounced and if it really was a local
thing then people would do it in other
words it wouldn't just happen in one
word so people would say big ol for the
kind of dog but they don't you know you
don't raise Biggles and if you look into
this it's very interesting this actually
was the invention of a marketing person
doing marketing stuff for the giant
eagle in the 1960s who came from
Philadelphia where they do do this so so
the Philadelphia Eagles you know the
football team is so but but because
we've seen it so much we go to the Eagle
video and it's even spelled it go this
way and they have the they have it on
their Flyers that they send you in the
mail and everything people really think
this is a Pittsburgh word even though
they don't they never actually heard
anybody say it oh this way um which is
very interesting then there's this
different ways of pronouncing a word
like wash wash some intrusive are just
means an R that's not really there in
the history of the word or whoosh
Washington yeah um that is very common
that's a Midwestern feature it seems to
be receding or that is going away you
hear less and less often um other
features nothing you saw this on your
way in um it's become a real sort of
marketing gizmo I mean I don't what you
call this but a subway I mean this
international global chain this is when
people talk about globalization they
often talk about how you sort of have to
reinstall
you have to remind people that they're
actually in a real place so you have
this global sandwich chain and you do
some little thing to remind people that
they're actually in someplace that isn't
just every place and what they do in
Pittsburgh is they put a local word in
they don't do that everywhere so that is
one of the things is the second person
plural pronoun it's related to EWTN's
you ones
it's very common all
through Appalachia although people don't
spell it this way except here they think
here it's thought to be one word and
people have sort of lost lost the
connection with you ones you ones
another form of y'all like it like
everything else I'll be talking about
we can't tell about the sounds we don't
have any recordings unfortunately of the
early scots-irish all we have is letters
some letters sometimes letters written
by people who weren't very literate can
show you something about how they
sounded or how they thought word sounded
but there's very little of that but
mostly these are all from scots-irish
and this one this one to the infinitival
copula the shirt needs iron the needs
fixed list that's an interesting one the
second ones from the newspaper
those are from also from scots-irish
people in Northern Ireland do this
people in Scotland do this they think
it's normal the next one I think is from
German I think it's more likely from
German than from scots-irish and there's
a little bit of research that suggests
this so instead of saying are you from
Pittsburgh somebody might say you from
Pittsburgh so when the question could be
answered with a yes or a No
you pass the bread it's generally it's a
question that you already think you know
the answer to when you already have some
idea what the answer might be like you
know you walk past somebody's garage and
they're painting the garage you say
paint your garage mmm that's an example
somebody gave me who wasn't from around
here but I grew up doing this I
apologize for that
um I grew up doing this and you're
irritating my parents with it and then
an ad as a general extender that is from
and
that and it's uh it's again not a
typical not not exclusively Pittsburgh
thing it's like etc and or stuff like
that
there are all sorts of forms of it it
tends to be found in working-class
speech and I was talking to somebody
about this before before the talk began
when you are in a situation where you
know everybody you see the same people
every day you go to
with the same people go to church with
the same people live in the neighborhood
with the same people work with the same
people you live in a very homogeneous
world you all live in the same world so
you can take a lot of shortcuts when you
talk a lot of stuff doesn't have to be
completely explicit so a form like this
you know an ad it just calls up a kind
of shared world it means that you you
expect that the other people know what
you're talking about and they'll be able
to generate the rest of this so that's
quite common in working-class speech
other kinds of shortcuts are - I'm
getting a little hot here so I'll take
this off so that's why it's I think
that's one connection that it has to
Pittsburgh it's working-class and people
think of Pittsburgh is working-class
what about african-american
Pittsburghers well most of the
african-americans obviously came from
the south
not not all there were a few free
african-americans who came from the east
originally they came from Africa of
course and both the African origin and
the southern origin probably influenced
the speech features that they brought
with them this is a contentious and
interesting question about what are the
origins of African American ways of
speaking English but they have something
African and something southern about
them in in Pittsburgh as in most other
northern cities African Americans
historically had relatively little
contact with whites because of de facto
segregation of all different kinds and
they had relatively little contact with
other African Americans who lived in
different neighborhoods this is one
thing that was different in Pittsburgh
they were because of the topography here
if there's not just one african-american
orange african-american neighborhood
there's a lot of smaller ones so there
was a lot of kind of social subgroups
less unity which means that African
Americans have never had much visibility
in local politics is it beginning to
change so as a result of this we don't
Africa we know that African American
Pittsburghers don't sound like African
Americans elsewhere because they tell us
that over and over again but the first
studies are just now being conducted
we've done fieldwork in the Hill
District and elsewhere fieldwork
collecting samples of
people speech talking interviewing them
about how they feel about the place and
what their social relations are like and
everything and there's a PhD student at
Pitt we don't have a linguistics
department here but if it does have a
linguistics department so this kind of
work tends to be done there who is
writing your dissertation about this and
it will be very very interesting
african-americans do claim some features
of Pittsburg ease though they'll say
it's the white people's way of sounding
but then they'll say but you know of
course I say the shirt their shirt needs
iron or I say Nabby and slippy and stuff
so what's going to happen to Pittsburg
ease people are concerned about being
authentic here as elsewhere I guess
there are reasons to expect local
sounding features to disappear and in
fact this is true across around the
world this is one of the things that
people have worried about or worried
about now on all sorts of different
scales imagine you've read some articles
or seen some coverage of the number of
languages whole languages that are
becoming extinct in many linguists are
very concerned about preserving those
languages in some way but dialects are
dying out to some of the sort of sub
regional dialects like the tip the
typical dialects of the islands off the
Eastern Shore of the United States like
okra coke some of the places where
Pittsburghers go on vacation those
places used to have very distinctive
accents because they were almost
completely isolated and they had a
indigenous economy they were fish they
based on fishing so there was very
little contact but then know more and
more that's a tourist economy in fact
it's almost exclusively a tourist
economy so people are exposed to the
wider world and suddenly their way of
speaking has less value for them and it
goes away and this happens over this has
happened over and over again in the
nineteenth century people started
worrying about local dialects dying out
and it's at this then as now it had to
do with social and Geographic mobility
people moving around
changes in migration patterns so you
know you have people coming in from
elsewhere a lot of northerners move to
the south have been moving to the south
over the last few decades and that means
that in southern cities there's a less
than less sort of strong southern accent
just statistically speaking although the
country saw is changing if you think
about North Carolina for example I mean
a huge migration from Mexico a huge
migration from this area I mean they're
probably more Pittsburghers in North and
South Carolina than there are in
Pittsburgh the mass media people often
think that the mass media is changing
language probably in some ways less than
you think but it does have some effect
after all radio has been around since
the 1920s and people didn't all suddenly
start speaking the same at that point so
you can overestimate the result of the
mass mean the effect of the mass media
the global economy there's new kinds of
jobs new kinds of employers it's in the
old days for men anyway if you worked in
the mill it didn't matter how you talked
it didn't even matter if you were
literate particularly if you were the
foreman it might be in fact to your
advantage to sound like the guys that
we're working with you
if you sound it too different from them
they might not trust you they might not
they might not like you but now more and
more people working the kinds of jobs
where it matters how you talk in fact a
lot of people have jobs where how you
talk is completely scripted you work in
a call center for example or you work in
a bank and you know the customer service
department of a bank the the phone in
Department you know the probably the
most extreme example of this is offshore
workers in India who do service kinds of
work and have people walking around
behind them making sure that they sound
like Americans and not only sound like
Americans but say exactly what's on the
script in front of them so it absolutely
matters how they talk it's quite
different than before women have always
had more jobs where it mattered how they
talked and when women in Pittsburgh
started entering the workforce they
might have become a teacher teachers
they might become recep
Genest and in both those jobs you know
it matters how you people think it
matters how you talk so women have
always been have always sounded a bit
less Pittsburgh II a bit more standard
than men and this is true every place
where you have the kind of gender
relations that you have in this kind of
this particular kind of economy where
women are more likely to have those
kinds of service jobs there are probably
some other reasons for expecting local
sounding features to disappear and I
want to come back to this if there's
time for discussion afterwards but first
I think there are also reasons to expect
local sounding features to persist you
certainly see lots of evidence of
Pittsburgh speech if you go down to the
strip if you don't live here go down to
the strip or go to Station Square and
you see these are all from t-shirts I
have a huge collection of t-shirts as
Eddie just seen chip Tam Sam you have
yeah I should have brought him um it's a
doll and when you push this and he has
on steel or a Steeler t-shirt he has a
mullet he's got some kind of polish
sounding name and when you press him in
the belly he says things in Pittsburgh
ease I mean that's bizarre that nobody
they didn't have that but you don't find
that anywhere else and you don't find
it's a local it's a homegrown business
um and you don't find that kind of thing
in other cities you find me not my fine
little dolls that somehow represent the
city but the fact that their speech
would be so important that you'd have to
have a little I don't know whatever it
is inside them t-shirts coffee mugs some
of this stuff has been around for a
while there was a there's some coffee
mugs dating from the 1970s I think that
we're prizes what do you call gifts you
could get for donating money to radio
stations but it there is more and more
of this stuff now so why would there be
more and more of this stuff if local
speech were disappearing I mean
obviously in one sense it's quite
obviously not disappearing it has
something to do with local pride
Pittsburghers are famous for being very
intensely loyal
for coming back years after they leave
for having to leave but not wanting to
leave there's also a phenomenon of kind
of solidarity in the face of dialect
endangerment people know people sort of
know that maybe not everyone talks the
way their grandparents did or the way
they do that they may be aware that
their kids don't do the same accident
that they do and they think wait a
minute this is going away this is an
element of our heritage that's going
away and maybe we should preserve some
of it not teach our kids to speak
Pittsburgh ease but at least you know at
least try to figure out what it is and
where it comes from and I think that's
what probably why a lot of you are here
it's why I have a big audience whenever
I talk about this so why would people be
so curious I mean in a sense you're sort
of part of my data here
then there's working-class pride this is
a sort of phenomenon that as you may
remember really started in the 1980s
with people like Bruce Springsteen if
you remember Bruce Springsteen kind of
working-class hero all the kind of
working-class movies with John Travolta
in them movies like The Deer Hunter in
1972 was a early example of this that
can sort of highlighting the connections
between working-class youth and Vietnam
and and that was actually a Pittsburgh
thing although Robert De Niro didn't
speak Pittsburgh ease doesn't so that's
been in and that has gone hand in hand
with the decline of
the actual working-class economically as
the working as their became got to be
fewer and fewer jobs for workers
starting in the 80s people got to be
more and more sore protective of that
image that identity symbols of localness
have become increasingly commodified
that is they're sort of for sale things
like this are commodities they're for
sale the History Museum is a commodity
that puts on a puts local speech on on
sale or offers it gives it some value
they don't have very much about speech
there but they're they have been
interested in the past so there are
various ways that local speech can have
a
kind of value that's different from the
value it would have had before it used
to have a kind of social value but it's
more and more it comes to have a kind of
economic value people use it in the
names of things people sell I mean I
have a hope did a hole a little project
about these shirts just thinking about
the economics of a shirt like this if
you buy a white shirt if you buy in bulk
500 white t-shirts like this from a
place in Aliquippa you can buy each
shirt for about printed already printed
for like three twenty nine or something
and you can sell them for five eight
dollars it's a very good markup and that
markup what's responsible for the
difference between a shirt that
originally cost a dollar fifty in bulk
and a shirt that you can sell for eight
dollars is local speech there's nothing
else nothing else gives it that value so
so that's it but that's a totally
different kind of value than local
speech would have had before so people
don't want to be homogenized I mean you
know nobody wants to be exactly the same
as anybody else you know even when you
think about kids in high school I mean
from the perspective of adults it looks
like all these kids want to be exactly
like all the other kids but they're not
they don't they don't look exactly alike
each one looks a little different and
that's I think a more general phenomenon
it's not just about social identity it's
about personal identity too you don't
want to be just like everybody else no
matter how cool we might think some
newer and more global kinds of
lifestyles and activities are we still
don't want to just be like everybody
else who's online or everybody else is
moving around every two years or
whatever so I want to just show you a
little bit about one way that this kind
of works that this that local speech is
now getting kind of reformulated that
its meaning is getting reformulated it
doesn't really mean it's not I mean
there are people who can sort of turn
local speech on because they want to
sound like locals but those are not the
same people who sound that way
they're doing it for a different reason
it has a different kind of value now so
a little bit about Pittsburgh ease in
the Steeler Nation the Steeler Nation is
one term for the Pittsburgh diaspora and
the NFL did it actual actually made a
film about the the Steeler Nation I
don't whether any of you saw Adam it was
aired very often but and they actually
had a segment about Pittsburgh speech in
it because this is one of the one of the
things that people sort of cling to no
it's not a lot of this is going to be
familiar to anybody in this room any
Pittsburghers have moved elsewhere to
find work starting in the 1960s when the
steel industry started to contract and
as I said before Geographic mobility
typically leads to dialect blowing so
that what you get is you don't get
everyone in the u.s. sounding the same
but you get a kind of northern sound
kind of middle sound a kind of southern
sound and that's about all there is in
the way of differentiation but on the
other hand geographic mobility also
leads to dialect awareness and I think I
was talking to you before right before
this about how that works you moved to
Boston and somebody tells you you sound
funny and you never realized you sounded
funny before so suddenly being become
aware of your accent it doesn't just
happen you don't just become aware of a
local accent because everyone you hear
has that accent if everyone you hear
sounds the same you don't become aware
of it everybody talked that way so older
people that I talk to in the in the
interviews I did would say yeah I'm sure
we said you know I'm sure we said Yin's
when we were growing up but we just
didn't hear it everybody did it it was
just not audible wasn't you you didn't
notice you couldn't notice it so
geographic mobility is what leads to
dialect awareness so you have this kind
of very interesting paradox I think this
is really what drives my project is that
at the same time that the dialect is
kind of going away people are becoming
aware of it it's almost in there almost
in in a kind of complementary
relationship and when Pittsburghers
elsewhere and hear talk of
pittsburg identity they often talk about
Pittsburgh's speech so one of the
mechanisms that's that's accounts for
this kind of increased awareness in this
increased connection of local speech
with local identity in its increased use
as a commodity is that it comes up when
people are talking about local identity
it's a way that you can frame local
identity I don't whether any of you have
been to steel or bar anywhere else but
here's one in Washington somebody and
notice what they have it they uh this is
on the ceiling basically are on a rafter
I'd like an iron aah
or in a chip chop sammich in a gum ban
give me a shilling iron and a Impa Norn
and then I don't know what this this has
a cord in front of it Steelers I don't
know what is what the decor is but no
jag-offs hey ain't no JAXA fetish and
then down here they have a t-shirt that
has some Pittsburgh words on it so this
is a one of the kind of places where
people gather the Steeler Nation film
that they made had a lot of footage of
these kinds of Steeler bars they're all
over the country there's a website where
you could go to find a list of all the
Steeler bars uh so I decide one way we
have gone about studying this is that I
did us a research study of a discussion
board that took place on a on WTAE in
1990 starting in 2000 this actually got
started when there was some news
coverage of a workshop about local
speech that we were having here but we
had nothing to do with it I did not
suggest it to this station so it was
kind of a grassroots thing so they put
up questions about local news I mean
they have discussions about local news
this one lasted far longer than any
other discussion they'd ever had usually
these last a couple of weeks we tracked
it for nine months and when there was
people were still contributing although
not too much anymore
there were a hundred and one
participants and they made 180 responses
so it's quite a robust set of data here
and here's a sample contribution
hae-in's guys I'm also an ex burger well
actually wishing wishing ttan County now
in Virginia too when I first went to
college at Edinboro I tried to get rid
of my accent because other students and
even the professor's were pointed out
why is it charming to have an accent
from one region and not another
it should not be embarrassing it does
not mean we are not intelligent people I
am proud of being from the Pittsburgh
area I think that the area is an
incredible melting pot of many different
cultures and if it's such an
embarrassment to talk this way if we
sound stupid how come I'm a university
professor and I still say campaigns pop
and drop the G off anywhere attending a
Ning what's an interesting argumentum
it's not that's you know this is an
interesting little rhetorical task here
but one thing I want you to notice is
how she establishes that she has a kind
of authentic right to speak about this
she identifies herself as a university
professor but at the very beginning she
says hey Yun's guys I'm an also an
expert actually wishing today oh so the
very first thing she does is she shows
that she knows something about local
speech by doing some local speech and
people do this over and over again this
is if you want to make a little argument
like this and this is an interesting
argument you know why would why would
people think this is stupid if
university professors do it why do we
like some accents and not others it's
pretty sophisticated argument but at the
very beginning she has to show that she
knows what local speech sounds like and
that's one way that these things
circulate so people on this discussion
board and that I think is quite common
the people in who study these sorts of
things but find this that people often
without even being prompted to will
provide information about where they're
from and especially in a discussion like
this where in order to get the
get the floor it's important that people
know where you're from so 65 of these
people even without being asked provided
relevant information like I was born and
raised in the Pittsburgh area etc and of
those 65 which we have information about
43 of them were Pittsburghers who lived
elsewhere so that's a pretty big
percentage and if it's true if if that
same distribution is true for the whole
sample of 101 there's no reason to think
it isn't just because the other people
didn't say anything about where they
were from it shows that this discussion
is pretty pretty dominated by people who
are members of the Pittsburgh diaspora
that's who contributes to this
discussion and I think it makes sense I
mean people who live elsewhere don't
maybe subscribe to the paper or listen
don't they certainly don't listen to
local TV but they may go to the website
and check up on things there many moved
away in the 1980s so they many of them
said I've been gone for 20 years so what
did they talk about what did they
mention sounds words that are different
in other dialects they talked about
y'all know because there were many of
more living in the south
I'm surrounded by yours now I'm the only
Ensor I know anymore one person said I
live in Minnesota now and that all they
say aboot things they say things like a
boot or I live in the south and they
drop their arse they also mention words
and sounds that are connected with being
local with being with a local lifestyle
especially a local lifestyle that a
child might have because they're
remembering their childhood mostly their
their adolescence maybe so they talk
about things like this on Sunday we
worked the cars and notice again he's
sort of performing local speech in
writing and his kids we were giving pop
for a treat we have gum pans in our desk
G jumbo doesn't that make sense read up
and then there is all the time and then
there's all the time great one in it so
it doesn't quite make sense at the end
but notice that how many of the words
and activities that he alludes to our
sort of childhood things on Saturday we
wash the cards for example and they also
mentioned sounds and words connected
with places so they say downtown a lot
they spell it that way and they talk
about the Mon the Mon I don't know that
they would pronounce it that way but I
think I'm pretty sure that they meant
the Mon not the Mon
oh that's scotch-irish
yeah not people think it's German but
it's similar to a German word and that
may be partly responsible for why it's
stuck around but it's really from
scots-irish yeah yeah so it doesn't
quite fit there really doesn't fit there
he's just but notice how eager this
person is to stick that in there
somewhere because he thinks it's a
Pittsburgh thing so he puts it in even
though it doesn't really fit so what
people are doing in this discussion is
they're kind of connecting place in a
dialect and identity and they're doing
this in different ways so here's a
common person one conversation you must
be completely
so what's interesting of people in
Cleveland don't do this they don't link
their identity with language but
Pittsburghers do all the time so thank
you very much to find out more we have a
website and you're welcome to email me
the website is going to be upgraded and
sometime in the next two months and it's
going to even have some podcasts on it
with explanations of local words but
it's also going to have a lot of other
stuff that has some samples from the
interviews and has some explanations of
some other things thank you for staying
connected with Carnegie Mellon
University to learn more go to WWE mu
edu
you